♪♪
Welcome to
"Your Fantastic Mind."
I'm Jaye Watson.
This is a show
exploring the mysteries
and the science of
the amazing human brain.
Daniel Meadows was
fresh out of college
and beginning the next
chapter of his life,
when he began suffering
debilitating headaches.
Those headaches turned
out to be a tumor.
One that was very close
to the area of the brain
necessary for language.
So Daniel did something
most of us cannot imagine.
He was awake for
his own brain surgery.
Morning, morning.
(Jaye)
Daniel Meadows still has
moments of total disbelief.
I'm ready as can be.
All right.
Let's do this thing.
(Jaye)
That all of this must be
happening to someone else.
Look at my nose.
How many fingers do you see?
Two.
Now?
One.
Great.
Give me a big smile.
(Jaye)
Just months after graduating
from Auburn University,
in Alabama, he is at
Emory St. Joseph's Hospital,
about to undergo
awake brain surgery
to remove a tumor.
Daniel's only symptom
of the tumor,
crushing headaches.
I was expecting,
meeting Daniel,
that he was not gonna
be able to talk to me,
or that he was gonna have
significant difficulties
in creating language
and communicating.
(Jaye)
That's because the tumor
took up residence
right next to the
part of the brain
we use to create language
and communicate.
You can see that this
is a relatively large,
uh, tumor.
It's about the
size of lemon.
Um, and is,
again, compressing
parts of the brain.
(Jaye)
The MRI images
are reversed.
The tumor is on the bottom
left part of Daniel's brain.
The inferior lobe.
Next to our communication
headquarters.
Today is MRI day.
Active MRI day,
is what they call it.
Apparently, I'm supposed
to be doin' things
while they have me
all hooked up,
to see where
my brain works.
(Jaye)
We meet up with Daniel
the week before surgery,
when he gets
a functional MRI.
♪♪
Uh, so we're gonna do
the first task,
the finger tapping.
Again, just think
the words to yourself.
Do not speak, and don't move
any other part of your body.
(Jaye)
By tapping his fingers and
thinking specific thoughts,
they can see which parts
of his brain light up.
Neurosurgeon,
Dr. Chris Deibert,
will use this to help him
navigate during surgery.
That MRI you had
was incredibly helpful.
(Jaye)
They don't know
if it's cancer.
They only know they need
to try to remove it.
And Daniel is
going to help.
We're even gonna take
out most of the tumor
while you're still
asleep, okay?
Then we're gonna wake you up,
we'll do the testing.
Um, the guys, have they come by
and kinda run through the--
a little bit of the testing
that we're gonna have you do?
Or have they
not come by yet?
(Daniel)
I haven't seen them.
Okay, so they'll
be by shortly.
(Daniel)
An apple.
What color?
(Daniel)
Red.
14 plus 1 is 15.
All right.
15 plus 1 is 16.
Months of the year.
January, February,
March, April, May...
What is Dr. Deibert
doing for you today?
He is takin' out
a brain tumor.
This is Paul Meadows,
my father.
Oh, nice to meet you, sir.
Nice to meet you too.
And then my mother is
over there, Anita Meadows.
(Jaye)
It's time to say goodbye
to his parents.
We thank you, Lord,
for your-your mighty power,
and who you are.
(collective)
Amen.
All right, love you.
Love you too.
Love you, buddy.
See you in a little bit.
(Jaye)
Daniel is the baby.
The longest of four.
From a close-knit family
whose passion is epic hikes
around the world.
But the mountain
they are facing today
is one they
never expected.
And so it comes down to what
is the glue in this family...
faith.
We'll do an incision
that starts like this.
The smaller the tumor,
the more critical this is.
This is a hard
tumor to miss.
We wanna monitor how well
he can talk and speak
during surgery,
so that we don't take out
part of the brain
that causes his
ability to talk.
♪♪
(Jaye)
Forty-five minutes
into surgery...
Daniel is awake.
Good job, Dan.
It's Dr. Deibert here, okay?
You're doin' wonderful.
Everything's going perfectly.
We're gonna do
the testing,
and then we'll let you
go back to sleep here,
once you wake up
a little more.
(Jaye)
For two hours,
he answers questions
about where he went to dinner
the night before.
What did you have
to eat last night?
Okay, so you
went to Outback?
Say, Outback.
Okay, very good.
(Jaye)
Identifies objects.
Good.
(Jaye)
Makes conversation.
Did you go to school?
Where'd you go to school?
Yeah.
(Jaye)
Counts backwards.
All while Dr. Deibert
works to remove the tumor.
So this is obviously
very abnormal here.
This is kind of
grayish color, okay?
This is normal
brain here.
We've had a couple speech
arrests directly over top,
more anterior,
over top of the tumor.
We can test and say,
we can direct an electrical
impulse to the brain.
And if a person can no
longer speak temporarily,
then we know that this is an
important part of the brain,
that this is an area that
we can't do surgery in,
and we have
to avoid it.
(Jaye)
It's an unusual situation,
to have a doctor inside your
brain while you talk sports.
So Dan, you a hockey guy?
Soccer.
You a Liverpool fan?
What?
Who do you watch,
besides Atlanta?
(laughing)
Yeah, they had
a tough match.
The brain itself doesn't
have any pain sensation.
And it's the reason
we can do this.
(Jaye)
After two hours...
(Dr Deibert)
Dan, you're doin'
great, man.
That's super,
super helpful.
Yeah, you're
doin' great, bud.
You're doin' awesome.
(Jaye)
...Daniel gets to sleep.
(Dr. Deibert)
There's kind of a little bit
of a hole where it was,
and the brain has started
to fill in that space.
100% success.
Um, his MRI after surgery
showed that completely,
the tumor had
been removed.
(Jaye)
Daniel's language
was not impacted.
The surgery
was a success.
But the pathology
overshadows that.
Now we know, again,
that some of those cells
have spread to other places,
most likely.
(Jaye)
Those cells that may have
spread to other places
are cancer.
Glioblastoma.
An aggressive,
high-grade tumor.
Hey.
It's good to see you.
You look much better
than last time.
Thank you.
Hey.
(Jaye)
Today's the meeting with
Daniel and his parents.
(Dr. Deibert)
So, as I told you
in the hospital,
surgery couldn't have
gone any better.
I mean-- and that-- a lot
of that is to your credit.
Everything that I can see
on the MRI is gone, okay?
Um...
(Jaye)
There is no easy way
to deliver this news.
This is some sort
of glioma, okay?
Okay.
Um, there are--
there is a little bit of
a range of gliomas, okay?
The, uh, ones that we hear
most about are things--
is a problem called
glioblastoma, okay?
Yeah.
And that's John McCain,
Beau Biden, Ted Kennedy.
We can't cure gliomas
with surgery.
This will recur
at some point.
No one can predict
the future.
Once you get, um, sort of
back into normal life...
(Jaye)
Daniel works to
absorb the information.
So you don't know
how severe or... not--
I mean, it-it's
a serious problem.
(Jaye)
From the first day
we met him,
when he didn't know
if his tumor was cancer,
Daniel told us this.
I haven't asked,
"Why me?"
I mean, I-I don't-I
don't see why
it should be
somebody else.
(Jaye)
They leave
Dr. Deibert's office.
Their plan includes
chemotherapy, radiation,
and faith.
Just the next step.
Yeah.
We always knew
there'd be a next step.
So...
Yeah.
One step at a time.
(laughing)
♪♪
Daniel has finished
radiation,
and is continuing
chemotherapy.
He worked full-time
through his treatment,
and says
he's feeling well.
We all feel lonely
or left out sometimes.
And now we know that
the cause could be
that you're not
getting enough sleep.
Most experts recommend
seven to nine hours a night.
But new research shows that
if you don't get enough sleep,
well, you could be
killing your social life.
Researchers at
UC Berkeley
found that sleep-deprived
people are lonelier,
and less likely to
engage other people.
Using functional
MRI brain imaging,
researchers had participants
watch videos of people
walking toward them.
When the person got
too close for comfort,
they could press a button
to stop the video.
Those who hadn't
slept enough,
hit that button far sooner
than the well-rested.
The study also found
that sleep loss
blunted activity
in the brain regions
that normally encourage
social engagement.
Now we have even
more reason
to get some
much-needed rest.
It's something millions of
Americans do each year...
get a massage.
For most, it's for relaxation,
or to help with body stress,
or pain from an injury.
But research is showing
that massage can have
a big impact on
cancer-related fatigue.
A condition that impacts
many cancer survivors.
Turns out,
the science of massage
is more than skin-deep.
(Fred Fletcher)
I've been very healthy
all my life.
(Jaye)
There are things 68-year-old
Fred Fletcher loves.
Like working
in his yard.
And if you look
hard enough,
you can find weeds
everywhere.
(laughing)
(Jaye)
And taking a cruise
around the neighborhood
in his favorite car,
a red Corvette.
(Fred)
It's just a fun
car to drive.
(Jaye)
But those things
fell away
after he was diagnosed
with prostate cancer.
The radiation treatment
was successful,
but left him
with relentless fatigue
that made him
consider retiring
from his job of almost
50 years with AT&T.
(Fred)
I work from home a lot.
And at noon, for lunch,
I'd come up and take a nap.
And then I go back to work
for a couple of hours.
Then I catch myself sitting
in my terminal, going...
(announcer on TV)
High level of fatigue
and low energy...
(Jaye)
During one nap,
this commercial came on.
(announcer on TV)
If you're frequently
bothered by fatigue...
(Jaye)
Fred joined a massage study
at Emory Brain Health.
(announcer on TV)
...suffering from
cancer-related fatigue.
(Jaye)
What was your experience
prior to this,
with massage?
I had zero.
None, whatsoever.
(Jaye)
It's the fourth such
study in nine years,
each one showing the
surprising power of massage
to help different conditions.
Is everything
comfortable?
Yes.
I tend to be really
skeptical about stuff.
And so... here was
this-this entity, massage,
and people were spending
billions of dollars
getting massages.
And when I started to
read about it, I said,
"Well, what's it doin'?"
(Jaye)
Dr. Mark Rapaport,
the Head of Psychiatry
at Emory,
launched the first study,
to see how just one massage
affects the body,
with participants getting
either Swedish massage
or light touch.
So even in unstressed,
young normals,
we saw that massage increased
the number of-of lymphocytes,
and increased the number
of lymphocytes that--
actually white blood cells
that had a marker
for what's called the innate
immune system, NK cells.
(Jaye)
A single Swedish massage
in a healthy person,
giving the immune system
a boost
and lowering
stress levels.
The next study
was with people
with Generalized
Anxiety Disorder.
After twice-a-week
Swedish massage,
participants reported
significant decreases
in measures of anxiety
and depression.
And those results lasted
months after the study ended.
Good morning.
(Jaye)
Rapaport and his team
then moved into the world
in which Fred Fletcher
was living,
the world of
cancer-related fatigue.
Great.
Thank you.
(Jaye)
The condition can affect
up to 80% of people
who get chemotherapy,
and 90% of people who get
radiation treatment for cancer.
Oh, that's terrible.
This fatigue may be
related to a low level
of chronic inflammation.
(Jaye)
By the time Fred signed up,
Rapaport and his team had
already studied massage therapy
on breast cancer patients.
And what we saw was
remarkable improvements
in two separate
measures of fatigue.
(Jaye)
Those measures,
the Multidimensional
Fatigue Inventory
and the NIH Patient Related
Outcome Measure of Fatigue,
showed that the
women found massage
provided clinically
significant relief.
(Dr. Rapaport)
So the question was,
one, um,
do men respond the same
to massage as women?
And two, do men with a very
different type of cancer,
also with fatigue,
respond?
(Jaye)
Once a week for six weeks,
Fred got a massage.
For an hour,
I was in heaven.
(Jaye)
He also had
his blood taken,
and rated his fatigue
levels on an app.
How often do you experience
extreme exhaustion?
Often.
How often do you
run out of energy?
Always.
(Jaye)
After six weeks
of massage...
(Fred)
Oh, I feel like
my old self.
Um, Sunday,
after church,
I was outside pulling weeds
for three-and-a-half hours.
I would probably still
be dragging around.
Lack of energy.
A cranky old guy.
(Jaye)
The rubbing and kneading
of muscles and joints
in the body was
affecting change
far deeper than
muscles and joints.
I think that massage
is changing and modulating
our immune system
in a way that decreases
sort of the chronic
inflammatory states
that occur in
certain disorders.
We're seeing a decrease
in inflammatory markers
associated with these
cancer survivors
who've been plagued
by chronic fatigue.
We need to do
more analysis there,
but it looks very,
very positive.
(Jaye)
Nine years in,
this research is making
a powerful connection.
I could not do
this before.
(Jaye)
That massage impacts not
just the body, but the mind.
Our body influences
the brain,
just as the brain
influences the body.
(laughing)
More trials will
soon be underway,
to continue to prove that
massage can relieve fatigue
in many different
types of cancers.
Giving an effective treatment
option to people who need it.
You don't need a study
to tell you
that having one of
these guys in your life
can make it better
in so many ways.
Research shows us that our
feel-good hormone, oxytocin,
actually increases when
we interact with our dogs.
Oxytocin is the hormone
that bonds us to our babies.
Now research is showing
that therapy dogs
can help decrease the symptoms
of ADHD in children.
In the study,
half of the children
attended a social skills
program.
And the other half went
through the same program,
but each had a therapy dog
at their side.
Both groups showed improvement
after 12 weeks.
But the group with dogs
showed marked improvement
after just 8 weeks.
They experienced
a reduction in inattention,
and an improvement
in social skills.
And an added bonus,
their parents reported
significantly fewer
problem behaviors.
Great news for parents
looking for options
to treat their
child's ADHD.
And really great news
for kids who want a dog.
It's probably one of
the most common
New Year's resolutions
we make... exercise.
How we're gonna
do more of it.
How, this time,
we're gonna stick to it.
We do it to lose weight,
to reduce stress,
to feel better
about ourselves.
But what if
exercise alone
could make
your brain younger?
According to research,
that's exactly
what it can do.
In the gymnasium at
the VA in Atlanta...
Switch to
the other side.
...conventional wisdom
is being challenged.
No hills today, right?
Uh, maybe a few.
(Jaye)
That wisdom...
How you been?
Yeah?
Good.
(Jaye)
...that most accept
as inevitable...
(man)
Everybody ready
just about?
(Jaye)
...is that after
a certain age...
(man)
Ruth, heart rate?
(Jaye)
...it's all downhill.
Good.
Keep climbing.
(Jaye)
But research is
showing us...
About 10 seconds.
(Jaye)
...that when it
comes to our brains...
All right,
Dee and Gayle.
(Jaye)
... we can reverse
that decline...
You're up.
You ready?
(Jaye)
... through exercise.
All right, sprint.
Doctors Joe Nocera
and Keith McGregor
are part of a team
that's been researching
exercise's effect
on the brain
for 10 years.
Good-- keep it up
a little bit longer.
So, I-I'm really interested
in the language function,
and how the brain behaves
during language function,
particularly how it
behaves in older adults.
And Dr. McGregor is really
interested in motor function.
And he studies just simple
finger-tapping movements.
(Jaye)
Aging people often have less
motor control in their hands.
They also often have
trouble recalling words
they want to use,
called tip-of-the-tongue
phenomenon.
Both are accepted
as typical,
yet frustrating
parts of aging.
But what these VA and
Emory Research scientists
discovered in
a few older people
early on
in their research,
is that their brains function
like those of young people.
And those older people
had something in common.
They were all incredibly
physically fit.
Marathon runners,
elite athletes.
Do get some inferior
frontal activity there.
(Jaye)
Researchers have
known for 40 years
that exercise helps
motor performance,
but Nocera and McGregor
wanted to learn how.
One big difference between
younger and older brains
are the areas activated.
You feeling good?
Yeah.
Well, you look marvelous.
So we're gonna go ahead
and get started.
(Jaye)
Dr. McGregor uses magnets
to stimulate nerve cells
in the brain,
called Transcranial Magnetic
Stimulation, or TMS.
The painless procedure
is FDA-approved
for treatment-resistant
depression.
But it can also
be used to show
how one side of the brain
controls and sends messages
to the opposite side
of the body.
This actually will sh-show
how one side of the brain
actually tells the other side
of the brain to be quiet.
(Jaye)
This quieting of one
side of the brain
is called inhibition.
Dr. McGregor demonstrates
on himself.
Okay, so the area that
I'm stimulating right now
is called the
primary motor cortex.
And so when I'm stimulating,
you're getting a response,
essentially,
in my arm,
and then down to
my hand. So...
(Jaye)
But as the brain ages,
in language and task,
inhibition is lost.
And both sides of the brain
begin to be activated.
And this increased activity
on both sides is not good.
It doesn't improve
performance,
so it's not compensation.
(Jaye)
And that's when language
and motor skills,
things we need to
maneuver through life,
get more difficult.
Back to those super
fit older people
in their early studies?
We found that individuals
who were highly fit
actually showed
br-brain activity
very similar
to younger adults.
That's to say,
they were only activating
one side of the brain,
and they were
inhibiting the other.
(Jaye)
Which is the way
it's supposed to be.
So--
Which is the way
it's supposed to be.
(Jaye)
So the question was,
could they take sedentary
older adults,
and through
exercise alone,
make their brains function
like a younger person's again?
Doin' good?
Yeah, 98 and 93.
Good, okay.
I'm liking it.
(Jaye)
Sixty-nine-year-old
Gayle Smith
is one of the
research participants.
I get there.
(Jaye)
As a retired
school teacher...
Good girl.
Come on.
(Jaye)
...Smith knew she
needed more than
the occasional yoga class
and playing with her dogs.
You went the wrong way.
(Jaye)
Gayle's bike neighbor,
Deidre Hurley,
has a similar story.
I was once active
at a gym.
But that was
many years ago.
(Jaye)
Like, how many?
And, um--
Oh, gee.
20-something
years ago.
(Jaye)
Three times a week
for 12 weeks,
participants take
a spinning class
20 to 45-minutes long.
It's an interval
aerobic workout,
involving low and
high intensity.
Ruth, heart rate?
96.
Stella?
The idea is that
they're continuously
pushing themselves
to be a little bit outside
of their comfort zone.
And once they do that,
they actually tend to show
growth or improvements
like we see
in this program.
(Jaye)
Changes in the brain are
measured through blood tests
taken before and after class,
and brain imaging.
In just 12 weeks,
a stunning change.
Our research is showing that
the brain, after exercise,
begins to show activity
that's more similar to
that of a young person.
(Jaye)
Brains that have been showing
activity on both sides
were now back to
lighting up on one side again.
So in a sense, yeah,
we are kinda turning
back the clock.
(Jaye)
Turning back
the clock how much?
It would be
fair to say
about a five to
seven year improvement
over the 12 weeks,
is-is what a person
could reasonably expect,
on average.
(Jaye)
A brain functioning five
to seven years younger
after just 12 weeks.
Results vary,
because people vary,
in biology and in effort.
Ed Jones is a lifelong runner
who was able to do the study
after an injury left him
unable to exercise.
The results
don't surprise him.
The American College
of Sports Medicine
has a logo,
"Exercise is medicine."
And I think they're
completely accurate on that.
It's sorta the
magic bullet.
(Jaye)
Magic that
requires effort.
But in a world where
youth reigns supreme,
and countless dollars
are spent by people
trying to turn
back the clock,
we can function as a younger
version of ourselves
by lacing up our shoes
and getting back
in the exercise saddle.
There are so many things
we cannot control in life,
but that doesn't stop a lot
of us from trying anyway.
This is the sort of science
that empowers us.
The proof is there.
Interval-aerobic exercise can
make your brain act younger.
Who wouldn't want that?
It does take away your excuse
to binge watch Netflix
on your couch
while eating snacks.
Loafing around
can feel good.
But to change your brain,
you need to move your body.
That's gonna do it
for us this week.
We'll see you next time
on "Your Fantastic Mind."
♪♪